you
[Music]
it is my great pleasure to welcome test
poster to Microsoft today as she is the
CEO of AI for all an organization that
is trying to increase diversity
inclusion and reliability of AI systems
in the world and you know she's she's
gonna be talking about the wonderful
work they are doing in that space
before joining AI for all she was
managing director of tech hire at
opportunity at work an organization
initiative lunch out of White House to
increase diversity in the tech economy
so very relevant and before that she
built and run Summer School and
nonprofit supporting love Inc low-income
people to find work in the digital
economy Tesla's work has been featured
in business insider TechCrunch and Fast
Company and she's gonna be talking about
how we can hopefully collaborate
together to make AI much more inclusive
in the future thank you so much thank
you all and I'm really so excited to be
here today and about both our existing
partnership with Microsoft as well as
new opportunities to really grow and
develop how we work together so to get
started
none of this is a secret to you but
obviously artificial intelligence is
really one of the most important
technologies of today and tomorrow it's
been called the new electricity the
driver of the fourth Industrial
Revolution and is clearly poised to make
incredible economic impact on society as
well as get embedded into our daily
lives and many of the things that
Microsoft is working on in terms of the
incredible impact there's also potential
for AI to create breakthroughs in
moonshots and solve some of the world's
most pressing problems and this actually
came out of the future computed which is
a report coming out by Microsoft earlier
this year
talking about some of the ways that AI
can impact the water supply issues
agriculture climate change biodiversity
and really create potential moonshots to
solve some of
problems and so there's tremendous
potential with this exciting technology
that has been around for a while but
because of new developments were
obviously in sort of an AI exciting
moment right now and it's getting talked
about a lot in the media as well however
given that this is such an important
technology there are some key risks to
both responsible and ethical development
of AI that I know Microsoft is really
focused on and has been leading in in
these areas this includes bias and
algorithms and machine learning systems
the diversity and talent crisis in AI
both in terms of industry but also in
research and academia education and
really the lack of access and knowledge
about AI so I want to talk a little bit
more about these issues the first is
around the diversity crisis and so we've
heard a lot about the diversity crisis
in the tech sector more broadly and AI
as a subfield of computer science it's
also pretty extreme and we call it an
actual crisis so some of the data shows
13% of AI and machine learning companies
are run by women and the numbers are
even more problematic and scary frankly
if you look at research tenure track
engineering faculty less than really 4%
minorities we also see and we hear a lot
of this working in different communities
talking and trying to expose people to
AI and just hearing what are their
perceptions what do they actually know
about it and some of the perceptions
that are out there are that it's the
Terminator it's coming to get you it's
the robot apocalypse it's scary it's
dangerous because it's going to take
over and automate all of our jobs and
what's going to happen
there's wildly different predictions
about how it's going to affect the
economy and the workforce and lastly
that it's exclusive and that you need a
PhD to get involved and really that it's
not for me this is what we hear from a
lot of our students at AI for all this
is not for me and so this perception
really is a problem because it prevents
people from getting involved in this
exciting field
as well as shaping our imaginations
about what is possible with the
technology we also see bias creeping up
in more and more decisions that are
affecting people's lives some of you may
be familiar with this research that came
out several years ago about how the
software called compass is being used in
the criminal justice system to help
judges make sentencing and parole
decisions and this software was studied
in 10,000 cases of it used in Florida
were actually looked at and there was
bias that showed up in these risk score
algorithms that were shown to be more
favorable towards white individuals and
and would have higher risk scores for
african-americans even with lesser
criminal background history so obviously
this is incredibly problematic for how
these systems are getting embedded and
already being used out in the wild and
affecting people's lives in such extreme
ways other bias examples and I'm sure
you all are familiar with many more but
this is one that obviously came out of
Tim McGee Bruce research from Microsoft
looking at facial recognition systems
and showing wildly different levels of
accuracy when you look at subgroups
including gender and race and obviously
these systems are getting embedded into
hiring processes into the criminal
justice system into the TSA and so
looking at accuracy and bias is critical
as these systems are getting more and
more prevalent prevalent in our daily
lives so this isn't just a problem for
sorry this isn't just a problem for
those individuals that are actually
affected these subgroups that we're
talking about it's also a problem
because these systems are being used so
a recent Gallup poll showed that 85% of
Americans use AI everyday this is pretty
impressive and it's just going to grow
so how do we actually address this
there are a lot of things that I'm
really excited to learn more about from
all of you that Microsoft is leading on
including better systems of how we test
monitor and audit AI systems before and
in the wild so we can track and and take
take actions actually mitigate some of
these fairness fairness and ethics
standards transparency and explain
ability and I know some of you in the
room are actually working on this and of
course lastly is diversity inclusion and
all of these we consider at AI for all
to be really critical and important to
addressing this and mitigating these
risks but we believe that one of the
most important things is to actually
address diversity inclusion and AI so
that's why we started AI for all which
is a nonprofit organization founded to
increase diversity inclusion in AI
development policy and research so not
just looking at AI development but also
all the different parts that this
technology will touch including the
education system government systems and
everyone needing sort of not just AI
literacy but to have more diversity in
all these areas that are going to be
shaping such important decisions so I
want to share a little bit about our
work so why did we start AI fro there's
a challenge when you're looking at
barriers to underrepresented populations
actually getting into the AI field and
touching the different ways that this
technology will impact all these
different areas in an interdisciplinary
perspective so in terms of the current
homogeneous culture in AI as well as
some of the perception issues that we
talked about earlier that doesn't
necessarily attract new people getting
into the field and can be a barrier
there's also a lack of exposure to
technical concepts in certainly AI so AI
is currently not taught in high schools
and it's not part of the computer
science education and in fact only 40%
of high schools have computer science
education even
not to mention that they're not
including new and emerging technologies
like AI and there's a few relatable role
models so a lot of the reason why we
choose different careers and why we want
to even go into these areas is because
of who we meet and get exposure to what
they do why they do it how they do it
and if we don't see individuals that we
can relate to it's much harder to
picture yourself going into that field
and a lot of these are actually based on
a Microsoft research study that came out
about earlier barriers to getting into
the computer science field and so we
actually built AI for all to address
each of these barriers and ensure that
people from all backgrounds are able to
get into the field there's also this
idea of peer community and support that
is lacking so if if you know that is not
prevalent at your high school for
example it can be much more challenging
to feel like you can go into you know a
computer science club for example that's
100% male if you're a young woman and
that's what we hear from a lot of our
students as well so we address this with
three core initiatives that are really
trying to not only bring more people
into the field to begin with but also to
support their pathway and long-term
success so our first initiative is a
summer camp program that exposes diverse
high school students to artificial
intelligence and we partner with some of
the top research organizations including
Stanford University Princeton UC
Berkeley and we actually bring students
into these research labs over the summer
for a two to three week camp and they
learn directly from AI faculty
researchers get technical exposure to AI
get connected with role models and
mentors and then also get to work on AI
projects the second piece is increasing
awareness and access to AI and this is
really getting back to the
reception issues that we talked about
earlier that AI literacy is really
becoming something that needs to be
basic for almost everyone participating
in our society in the future
and then lastly research I want to talk
a little bit more about each of these
pieces the first is our summer camp
programs which I talked a little bit
about before and so we last year we had
summer camps operating at Stanford and
UC Berkeley and this summer we're
tripling the number of schools that were
at and as you can see each of these
schools focuses on a slightly different
population as well as different
geographical focus I wanted to share
with each of you a little bit more about
the curriculum that we've developed in
partnership with these universities as
well as our team so the first piece is
technical exposure our camps are pretty
rigorous because we want to give
students that hands-on exposure to some
of the key concepts and importantly
ethics and the societal implications of
AI are really a lens that is throughout
all of the pieces that we share with
students even the technical concepts
we're always talking about what kind of
bias could potentially creep up here
what are some of the mitigation
strategies and what are the implications
that this will have both positive and
negative in the world and what are some
of the frameworks that you can that are
getting developed although there's not
like a consistent framework out there
now we are exposing our students to some
of these frameworks getting developed
we're also giving them the opportunity
to get involved
so on Monday we're going to be launching
the first-ever high school committee
committee with the I Triple E ai and
ethics of autonomous systems initiative
and so young people are actually going
to get a chance to be involved in this
conversation and shaping what some of
these standards are and getting their
perspectives in the mix since this
generation is really going to be the one
that is most impacted by the decisions
that we make today it's critical that we
involve them at these early stages so
the second is soft skills and career x
and so again this is going back to the
need for role models and mentors and so
we bring in individuals from our
industry partners and all different
parts of AI to really understand what
kinds of careers are out there what does
it actually look like day to day and
also developing that peer and mentorship
community that's so important for
students the last piece which is really
exciting and I think we've found has
been one of the most successful ways at
engaging diverse groups of young people
in AI is to actually create AI for good
projects so not only our students
getting hands-on exposure to practice
some of the skills that they've
developed earlier on but they also are
seeing what are the exciting
applications of this technology for good
and to solve some of the big challenges
in the world today we've seen that this
has not only captured our students
imaginations for that they've gone on to
work on AI projects afterwards start AI
clubs at their schools and even win
awards yes for these summer camps that
is happening at Indian universities like
like do some of them focus on research
some of them are more on the curriculum
for learning about these topics or it's
it's a mix or its greatest from
university university yeah that's a
great question
so our summer camp is structured in a
way that we have a core curriculum that
focuses on those technical concepts that
we mentioned and each camp sticks to
that and tries to keep that consistent
across and then we have obviously those
in-person activities that might vary in
terms of which individuals are on the
career panels and all of that and each
University is responsible for developing
AI research projects and partnership
with us but that really is based on some
of the research being done about in
those labs as well as what the faculty
and PhD students are really passionate
about so it's very much you know taking
advantage and leveraging the assets that
are at those universities for the
research prod
I'm sorry innocence
oh no problem there two to three weeks
long depending on each site and they're
pretty intensive so it sits all day and
then they do fun activities at night so
one of the things that we learned this
past year in expanding and tripling the
number of camps is that there's
incredibly high demand for these types
of skills so one of our program little
programs only has 20 slots got 900
applications and so we were like wow
this is amazing we also get a lot of
interest from all over the world and how
do we embed AI curriculum into what
we're already doing places in every
continent basically so we decided that
we want to open-source our curriculum
and really try to scale the learnings
that we've had and make this available
worldwide and we see that there's
tremendous scale potential here this is
very early stage and we look forward to
launching it later this year the third
piece of what we do that's very exciting
is taking graduates from those first two
programs and connecting them with
mentors to work on more rigorous and
longer term AI projects obviously having
portfolios an actual demonstrated work
product is so critical in both your
education and your career these days so
we're really trying to develop students
portfolios so we just finished a cohort
two weeks ago and we had students
working with mentors from IBM from
Pandora from open AI working on research
projects and here are some of them so
using AI to detect wildfires ranking the
urgency of ambulance calls and
personalized this student on the right
working with a mentor from opene I built
a math tutor that is adaptive and
personalized that she's planning to
actually launch so we see incredible
results when we pair our young people
with their passions and connect them to
that support in that mentorship oh yes
please for mentorship
what is the both the students are the
undercurrents of graduate students high
school students high school students yes
yes so there are all 10th through 12th
graders so we talked a little bit about
AI Pharrell's work and why we think
diversity is so critical in mitigating
the negative impacts like bias and the
other ethical risks and artificial
intelligence but really diversity is
critical also for maximizing the
potential for AI breakthroughs and
moonshots and so if we increase
diversity and AI at these early stages
especially we're going to see more
innovative products a more diverse set
of problems actually addressed as well
as the network effect of bringing more
people into the field and I want to
share several case studies that showcase
this so we know that diversity is just
generally good for business
recent Intel report showed that if we
increase diversity in the tech economy
it could add five hundred billion
dollars to national GDP so it's it's a
good business proposition additionally
we'll see greater innovation from
increasing diversity so recent study
from Raj Chetty showed that if we
increase early exposure to innovation
the innovation economy to women
minorities and low-income students the
rate of innovation in America would
quadruple this is no small thing and so
it's really important to have that early
exposure so that we can maximize
innovation in our economy the second
thing is we might miss out on untapped
talent that might develop the next big
thing in AI or otherwise and I'll show
you the example of Amy so Amy graduated
from our Stanford AI for all program in
2015 and she was so passionate about AI
she'd never been exposed to it before
that she kept on with her research and
how many of you have heard of the nips
conference okay everyone so Amy won best
paper award going up against
of adults for her research on improving
surgeon technique using machine learning
this is pretty amazing for a student
that's still in high school and so we
don't want to miss out on talent like
Amy that might develop the next big
thing and if Amy had never heard of AI
or never been exposed to it she never
would have had that opportunity we also
see that if we increase inclusion and
diversity a more diverse set of problems
more creative set of problems will
actually be addressed so I want to share
the story of Stephanie so Stephanie is
from Salinas California not sure if any
of you are familiar with Salinas but it
is an area where she actually grew up as
a daughter of farm workers in a very
low-income family first-generation
mexican-american and she graduated from
our program and not only did she start
an AI Club at her high school which is
pretty impressive and she's teaching
younger students about AI she's doing
research to track the flow of
contaminated water using machine
learning with her mentor from Accenture
and this is something that she's still
in the early stages of but she wants to
bring this back to her community because
it's something that's faced her both
personally and directly
so here's Becca so Becca went through
our AI for all program and she was
really torn between sort of her her
passion for social justice and
humanitarian work but through exposing
her to all the different ways that AI
can be applied for good and to benefit
humanity she became really really
passionate about combining those two
pieces together so I'll just share her
quote seeing the humanitarian
applications in AI at Stanford AI for
all I realized that I didn't have to
sacrifice fundamental aspects of my
identity to pursue computer science I
loved computer science and I see it as a
tool to utilize in art music and
political advocacy stem can be really
powerful when applied to other fields so
we see that if we increase diversity
we're not only going to get more
creative use of
a I discover untapped talent that we
wouldn't have found before but also new
interdisciplinary ways to apply a I to
different fields and really tap into
people's unique passion and interests we
also see that when we increase diversity
and inclusion it really has this network
effect that we've seen that's been
really really powerful so most of our
students leave AI for all programs
wanting to pursue AI and feeling like
they're part of this incredible
community and what that's led to is that
they go on to educate their peers as
well as their community and we track
this so for every one student that we
educate they go on to educate 11 more
and so when you bring more people into
the field it has this incredible
multiplier effect they bring their
friends they bring their friends and
just a small investment in one person
can be really powerful in making an
impact there we also see the same thing
with organizations and companies I think
Microsoft is certainly a great example
of this where when one company steps up
and invests in you know really this
principled approach to AI development
and really looking at bias and
mitigating that at these earliest stages
as well as investing in the next
generation of talent it then brings
other leaders into the field and it
shows the way and it influences other
companies so these are a lot of our AI
for all partners that we currently work
with and the list is growing so I think
it's really important not just to have
inclusion and diversity bringing in
individuals into the field but also in
showing other companies and
organizations and institutions that
really need to step up and be leaders in
this way and bring their their
colleagues and peers along so I want to
talk a little bit about how you all can
get involved with us so we currently are
really excited about our partnership
with Microsoft and there's a couple of
specific ways that I've said
here that we'd love to continue
deepening this work that we're doing
together but I also want to hear from
you all there are other things the first
is recruiting so we are obviously
graduating an amazing set of the next
generation of AI leaders and so if you
have internships if you have an
apprenticeship program if you're hiring
consider AI for all a source of talent
for for these roles secondly we have
many many volunteering opportunities for
folks to serve as mentors for this next
generation of talent a mentor can
absolutely change someone's life and
change some someone's trajectory and we
have both one-day opportunities as well
as these longer-term opportunities to
support students on an actual research
project and share feedback again that's
such an important part we consider this
a dialogue and a two-way street that we
want to learn what are you all finding
in the best practices for mitigating
bias what are some of the challenges and
nuances that you're seeing in your work
and how can we leverage those learnings
to prepare the next generation to do
this well and to make the right
decisions so we want to hear from you
and and work closely on that I know you
also do a lot of outreach and education
yourselves and some of you in the room
are doing that and I want to hear more
what's working how can we partner and
collaborate on those efforts this
problem is obviously not something that
one organization or one company can
solve so it's really important for us to
come together and really solve this
together so with that and if you are
interested in volunteering I have a link
right here that makes it really easy to
sign up and you can let us know if
you're interested and in what capacity
and also our contact information but I'd
love to hear from the room if you have
questions either about our work or ideas
for ways that we can work together to
both support the next generation of
diverse AI leaders but also ensure a
responsible and ethical use and
deployment of this important technology
so any questions thoughts feedback yes
no program you show that so the number
of students taught which is extremely
impressive how are you getting that that
volume of touch when you say in programs
are sort of only accept twenty students
yeah that's a great closure number
contraction
yeah so right now our main programs are
at these universities that have you know
between twenty and thirty slots and I
think what you're referring to is our
open sourcing project that we've is
really our scaling plans so we're
getting so much demand and so much
interest and we believe that this access
to AI tools education and resources
should be widely accessible and that's
not getting addressed right now at least
in the u.s. at the K through 12 level so
we're taking the the curriculum and
learnings that we've built for our
summer camps and open sourcing them to
make them more widely available which we
have the goal of reaching millions
through that model by working with
existing partners schools and and
companies who are already in the doing
this work thank you good question so
when you're summer camp curriculum what
are the kinds of applications you have
the kids working on yeah so we focused
on robotics computer vision natural
language processing and each of the
universities develops a set of projects
that are focused on those applications
but are all around AI for good so for
example looking at social media data and
analyzing that after a natural disaster
we were looking at after Hurricane sandy
dataset to see how would you better
funnel resources towards that in
response to sort of lessen response
times and make them more accurate or
making hospitals safer using computer
vision or how does the self-driving car
revolution affect mobility for aging
populations so so those are some of them
and we have about four to five prod
at each of our universities that are
co-designed with those researchers and
faculty it's a great question because I
when I look at most curricula especially
for kids you see sort of the same things
come up again and again like robots and
hurt like a kid likes like one of the
ones you showed who's really interested
in social justice that's just not going
to be a turn-on so I love the approach
you're taking thank you yes what data
sets for these isn't that the program
hasn't has data set that all different
University usual or other researchers
and the different institutions for
finding the data sets yeah it's a
combination obviously getting good data
sets is one of the key challenges right
and so that's part of what we try to
teach our students it's how do you find
the right data set how do you analyze
the data set so you know it's quality
what is the size matter where do you
host it all that and so that's why we
certainly provide some of them but we
also allow the students to try to go out
and identify where can you find this
kind of open source
we've also leveraged tools like Kaggle
and other other kind of open source
tools that are out there and in some
cases the universities will provide
those datasets it's a great question yes
you a lot of opportunities for people
who are you know have already sort of
studied a field and sort of looking to
move into it because these are I think
mostly focused on students high school
students who are interested in getting
into it and they haven't had you know
education shaped in a particular way but
you also have opportunities for people
searching fields that's a great question
so currently we don't so our summer
camps are mainly for high schoolers but
our open source curriculum will be
available and opened for anyone to use
because obviously there there is a gap
in basic AI training at all levels so
it's good question other questions yes
in creating like an annex or courser
course and the approach of summer
schools so you know I feel like the
impact you are having you cannot really
excess it if these students are sitting
at home and just watching the material
in an online race there seems like
there's a human touch part meeting with
people there working with them and
getting their hands dirty so in terms of
scaling that open sourcing the contact
is one part of it but I guess you still
need partners in different parts of the
country and even the world that aren't
gonna physically have hosts these camps
and be the mentors I'm kind of trying to
understand how much of it is going to be
the open source content that scales and
how much of it is still going to be like
the organizational and hands-on and weld
one mentoring kind of style
absolutely ya know it's a good question
and we find obviously a lot of the
barriers for people that are currently
excluded from these fields have to do
with lack of role models and mentors and
those pieces and we don't want to miss
that
in these new models so in terms of our
open source and curriculum it's not
going to be just a MOOC so there will be
some materials that will be openly
available but then we also are working
with partners closely who are already
teaching let's say CS classes or run you
know after-school stem programs that can
actually provide that in-person
component so absolutely we don't want to
miss out on that because the peer
community that human touch as you said
is really a critical part of why our
programs have been successful we also
will be offering again that mentorship
fellowship opportunity to students that
want to continue their learning we also
see that with the open source piece that
will really give people exposure to what
is available in this field and then they
can take that knowledge further so we'll
be really really I think there's a big
gap right now in terms of what is even a
career in AI so the work that you all do
is absolutely so interesting
and if if more people could understand
like what are the different pathways
what are the things that you can work on
I think that will inspire a lot of
people to pursue this and so we're also
going to have sort of like a career
exploration component and element where
people know hey if I am really
interested in research and what does
that actually look like I can go in this
pathway in this direction so I think
that will give them specific steps of
how to move on to that that next phase
of their learning good question
other thoughts it seems like the program
covers the education part and then the
research part as partners but this to me
like there is a gap the industrial part
is missing here because there is now
very it's more like a common practice or
will become more common in the industry
part in the engineering segment as well
as a teacher scientist in an analyst
this part is sort of missing is so is
there a specific reason why you focus
just to focus on research instead of
that's a great question so I think
that's where our industry partners come
in and are so critical to this so we're
actually working with a lot of different
AI focused companies that can offer our
students both internship opportunities
Job Shadow opportunities mentor
opportunities to really get exposure to
what these different careers are not
just in research we focus on research in
the class itself because that's a fun
and hands-on way for students to get
exposure to some of the applications we
also do cover some Python coding but
they're also when you look at the
computer science education world there
are actually a lot of organizations that
are doing really amazing work in
teaching coding and engineering and
computer science and so we're not trying
to duplicate that we're actually trying
to be complementary so if somebody wants
to continue and deepen their Python
skills we provide them with resources
but we're really not a coding program
and so both we're trying to provide that
exposure to industry through our
partners and connecting students so at
each camp will have many guest speakers
from industry talking about their work
their applications and we have career
roundtables and mentorship opportunities
so they are still getting that exposure
to the different sides of it and we're
not trying to say you should go into one
or the other
it's it's not really a directive
experience it's really like here are the
broad opportunities and you need to
select which path is right for you and
here's what you need to be successful in
that path and we'll support you but
we're certainly agnostic in terms of
what the opportunities actually are
great question
yes this is really amazing well thank
you for sharing with us I have a
question about the innovation beyond the
education the innovation that's coming
out of the projects that some of the
students are doing what mechanisms do
you have in place to nurture and sustain
or provide some sort of path forward the
example that you gave with the water
contaminated water flow so how what what
formal mechanisms have you put in place
to do that yeah that's a great question
so we're actually expanding out our
alumni program right now with that exact
goal in mind we found that students I
think it was pleasantly surprising to us
that a lot of students wanted to
continue that research already in high
school and so we are putting more formal
mechanism mechanisms into place as well
as keeping that community element going
so we have ongoing educational
opportunities we are now starting to
place students at internships as they're
sort of graduating high school and into
college as well as providing
opportunities to continue their research
and so that's really the purpose of the
the fellowship and then again the
relationship with the industry and
academic partners great question
it's really really important because
obviously we want them to be able to
take these solutions further and out
into the world
other questions yes this will be a very
pithy question but um AI is such a broad
technology and we're expecting to have
such broad impact right on every
industry and lots of different aspects
of life but so much the discussion is
still starts from a technical
perspective rather than a different
perspective like social science
perspective or a agricultural
perspective right and the solutions are
needed within those communities and have
technology can help earth better a lot
of are more likely to be productive if
they start there and then starting from
technology and I notice the younger
people getting into the field tend to
have a more natural affinity towards
thinking about things more broadly but
I'm wondering about programs like this
especially with the youngest people who
are getting in how can they be
encouraged to think about it from from
multiple perspectives or from a very
specific perspective that they're super
into but it doesn't necessarily start
with the technology I think that's
exactly what we see is that the
application first approach is what is
most effective at engaging young people
into the field and we actually don't
consider you know just technical AI jobs
as the goal it's really about an
interdisciplinary approach which we know
is needed in terms of how this
technology is going to impact all these
different industries all these different
areas so I'll give you one example our
Princeton program is more focused on AI
policy and they're actually taking a
field trip to Washington DC and
connecting with key leaders who are
thinking about that on a broad level and
even though it still has that technical
rigor because that technical exposure is
important and understanding that in a
deep way not just glazing over it is
really critical but we want to make sure
that students are getting exposed to you
know how is this going to affect the
criminal justice system how is this
going to affect social services get
embedded in healthcare you know all
these different areas and so I think
that's both in reflected in how we
actually teach it
starting with the application and then
moving into the technical side as well
as the kind of projects and other
exposure that our students are getting
thank you that's a great question I'm
really critical I think yeah I have a
multi-part question but I think I'll
just start with an easy one how much
does the summer camp cost yeah great
question so most of the camps are free
or very low cost for the students so
access is absolutely critical and we
have full scholarships available for
those that can't pay even if there is a
fee and then do you do like named
scholarships like let's say a company
gives a chunk of money to your
organization does that then end up in
like branded scholarships for students
or hug is there what kind of play is
there to integrate industry partnership
donations with your organization that's
a great question we haven't done that
yet I think we'd be open to it
for sure I mean access is is absolutely
critical in providing this education for
students that need it most we currently
work with funders that kind of more
support general operations or that
haven't specifically done like a
scholarship fund per se but yeah
definitely open to those discussions
because every statistic that it's cost
like up to 5x to recruit a diverse
employee right like it there's an
extreme cost to doing this at scale but
it seems like you're also you're
cultivating that such top talent with
with this field that it makes sense for
an industry partner to potentially like
you know give something the first
Pacific scholarship work or a specific
opportunity so I just think there's like
a huge point for piece play I know is it
is that part of your docket today to
talk to plan if it reads a little bit or
has that conversation started
yeah Microsoft is already a financial
supporter of the IPL so that's great and
we'd love to talk about increasing that
for sure thank you other questions how
are we doing on time
another 40 45 minutes oh wow oh well you
can also keep it shorter and my son
first of all we just started this
partnership and only a mess our side the
outreach team is in contact with tasks
about planning and deciding next steps
but I think we can do a lot together and
if you have feedback for the outreach
team you know this is one of the things
they are they're thinking about either
we can talk to test-firing internally
with outreach team those are already
think possibilities and that's one of
the reasons why that's here today just
like that connection my question is for
a program where there are like nine
hundred applicants and 20 spots what
does the current solution yeah so we
have an application process that is
mostly qualitative so we ask key
questions like about leadership their
interest in AI they don't have to have
any coding experience or AI experience
this is specifically trying to attract
students that are not coming in with
that so it's a set of essay questions
mostly kind of like maybe you'd see in a
college application process we do look
at math and what math background they've
they have because if they're not at a
certain level it will be more
challenging to get through some of the
more technical pieces of the course but
most young people that are at a ninth
grade math level and above are good and
then yeah I think in terms of where we
recruit from just to add on to that we
actually found that doing direct
outreach within high schools and working
with teachers directly is the most
effective because there isn't a lot of
knowledge out there about what AI is
what those terms even mean
and there's a lot of misperceptions
about what it is there's a lot of fear
out there making that human connection
with students and sharing what is this
really and what are the opportunities
and you know what kinds of jobs can you
get in this area
has been really successful at bringing
in students that wouldn't otherwise get
exposure to this great question anything
else yes and I don't know it who would
speak to this but you have an envision
for a role that MSR might be able to
play in this other than you said a lot
of your industry partners provide
internships and things like that but
went by quickly but the universities
that are involved none of them are sort
of in this area is there thoughts of
running camps in the Seattle area or
what type of yes I mean so we're
definitely interested in expanding the
summer camps I think given this group
and the focus here research is a really
exciting area so we do have this
fellowship program that does focus on
connecting researchers in the field with
our students and helping us design the
right researchers there's also
opportunities for I think thought leader
shared thought leadership around what
ethics frameworks should we be including
in our curriculum and how can you all
advise on that based on what's actually
happening in this space I think there's
some education opportunities that we're
going to be talking about later as well
in terms of how do we collaborate on
outreach or education in addition
initiatives that you all are already
doing and sharing cross learnings and
we're also in contact with the tiel's
program and so actually we connected
with them to recruit for this year for
the summer camps and so how do we kind
of tighten tighten that partnership even
more so those are those are some of the
key areas I think there's expansion you
know the technical content research
mentorship and and taking advantage of
all the amazing talent here and
connecting that with the next generation
and then of course us being a potential
source of talent for you all as these
young people go into the field but we
are certainly opened other ideas
I think again these conversations are
just at the early stages and we're
excited to build a deep and long-term
relationship so I'd be eager to get
folks feedback as well I wonder if you
thought about also doing some young
participants back to industry feedback
right mmm it is it's not just that we
need to recruit people who look
different than other population does
it's that we need to understand how it
needs to be different in order for that
to be a healthy thing to happen I also
think that these young people like
theirs we have a lot of misperceptions
about them as we get older and how they
think about privacy and how they think
about security and how they think about
their own personal agency and how they
think about technology and we could
learn so much by having them talk to us
about those things and I think they
could feel very very appreciated and
empowered by having the opportunity to
teach us but they know that we don't
absolutely I think that's a amazing idea
and it's very kind of reflective of what
we're doing like with I Triple E that I
mentioned earlier where we're actually
having the young people give substantial
feedback on some of the standards and
working groups that they're developing
so I think that kind of approach would
be amazing and I don't know what format
exactly that could take but I think we
would find if you met any of our
students that they're skilled passionate
energetic smart enough to offer like
really helpful feedback in those ways
and that I learn a lot from them
certainly but I'm sure everyone else
wouldn't do thank you for that we have
two questions kind of no more oh great
yeah one of them is asking would love to
hear
populations are underrepresented if AI
is the new electricity to be needed TVA
or IEA to ensure it reaches more
Americans yeah that's a really really
great question absolutely we consider
rural underrepresented and we actually
do outreach to make sure that so a lot
of our camps are actually residential
which means our students stay overnight
and so it is it can be accessible to
folks not just coming from those areas
where the schools actually are which at
least right now are primarily you know
in in cities and so we are a I for all
so we absolutely consider those areas
that are most at risk of getting left
out of this conversation and being part
of shaping it to be our target focus so
and in fact we were really interested in
also expanding our camps to other
geographies to make the geographical
footprint more diverse as well as this
open source piece because access is such
a huge huge issue I think though one of
the challenges I've worked in rural
areas in the past and bandwidth and
Internet connectivity 50% of low-income
households in the u.s. don't have access
to internet at home which is shocking to
a lot of people but even if you go to
like a local library the the bandwidth
may not be good enough to even run a
YouTube video so how do we address that
and more of an infrastructure level so
that we can really provide access to
rural areas that are really left behind
in the digital divide question is we
keep hearing about an identical
framework and principles do you have a
draft of those principles what is the
road map or having a broad agreement on
the frame
and principals yeah that's a great
question so we are not a framework
development organization ourselves the
best that we can do right now is really
really stay connected to the
conversations of who is developing those
frameworks so for example like I
mentioned I Triple E they're AI and
autonomous systems ethics initiative
it's a long name has great work being
done on creating those standards and
they actually just put out a paper
called ethically aligned design that has
a set of principles that they put forth
that were developed in these working
groups from very diverse areas and I
definitely recommend taking a look at
that
it's it's you know a really interesting
and in-depth I what yes exactly
there's a group called partnerships on a
I bet that Microsoft is also involved
with that is working on creating working
groups to create standards as well and
so I think there's a lot of these
initiatives that we're seeing happening
and we're not putting forth one of these
kind of set of standards but rather
exposing our students these different
initiatives that are going on and what
some of the nuances in the discussions
are so I hope that it that answers the
question any other questions which is
you know last year there was the Google
employee I think there was this memo
from a Google employee it's on kinder
BOTS overall woman in the field you know
how there is positive discrimination and
actually like versa because of badness
of one human being has become belly and
you know being in this community how do
you think we are reacting to it
kind of these kind of kind of back
lashes or hope to be changed a culture
I'm just curious about your thoughts
about all of these discussions that are
going on in this today it's not so much
about high school students but about the
industrial era ya know it's a really
really great question and I think
there's been a lot of attention on it
lately like with the me2 movement and
certainly that memo that you're
referring to and I think as more and
more people speak out and more and more
research is also being done in terms of
retention in the tech sector and what it
actually takes to not just ensure that
we're hiring diverse workforce but
ensure that we're retaining them that
they can be successful in advance and
move up because obviously as we talked
about earlier that's good for business
and good for individual teams but I
think inclusion has emerged as a really
important second leg so at first the
conversation was all around diversity
and improving your hiring numbers but
this you also need to retain this talent
and so having an inclusive culture is
equally important and I think we see
companies investing in mentorship
programs having the right policies there
are tools that are cropping up to
support that both in the hiring process
for example to reduce bias as well as
support systems for employees that are
currently experiencing harassment or
discrimination I mean I think ultimately
it's it whenever there's more honest
discussion and people are speaking out
about these issues and it becomes more
more honest and people that have been
maybe victims of unfortunate
circumstances are able to have a voice
there's always going to be a backlash to
that and I think it's we need to have
the hard conversations we need to look
at the data and we need to be really
really proactive and and track all of
these metrics and hold ourselves
accountable to to solving these issues
because it's not just a problem for the
individuals it's a problem for the
companies it's a problem for the teams
and
it's everyone's problem I think that's
my own perspective is that it's not just
a problem for women to solve it's a
problem that affects everyone and
everyone loses if certain groups are
left out so I hope that the conversation
continues I hope that we're able to have
the difficult and challenging
conversations that might be
uncomfortable and I hope that we can
address this and I think with AI it's
such an exciting moment because while
we're seeing a lot of challenges and
certainly there's a diversity crisis in
the field there's also the opportunity
to address it at these early stages and
kind of steer the train in a better
direction so I'm very optimistic or I
wouldn't be doing what I'm doing but I
also think we have to be proactive in
all sorts of ways it's not just going to
take one magic bullet and it's not just
going to take one organization it's
going to take a community in our whole
society coming together and
collaborating to solve solve this
challenge great question
thank you
[Applause]